we knew we were making a book
we didn't know what book like what kind
of book
[Music]
one of the amazing things about this
project is that it actually took us
longer than
than building a big building to actually
build this book
originally the project was supposed to
take one year
it wound up taking three and a half
care is a book about
how to hack caring for dementia at home
carers always tend to be short-handed
under-resourced stressed and they're
always going from emergency to emergency
the vast majority of carers are not
professional carers and when we started
to look for books we found only high
level principles things like be
patient-centric care for the carer we
kept saying it has to be something that
everybody knows it has to be like the
Ikea catalog
the first major modification is the
famous puang chair which has I think
been in production for many decades
already
many older adults have you know muscular
atrophy in their legs and they use their
arms to get out of a chair so the
question was how do we then take this
thing that everyone has already and make
minor modifications to it
we particularly like Ikea as a kind of
model for this it's so accessible it's
so kind of non-threatening as well
we had a lovely launch here and the end
Foundation promised to give out books
for free to anybody who wrote in to ask
for them
I love this particular story of this
person who wrote in and he said you know
I don't I don't have anybody I know
suffering from dementia but I care for
dogs with mobility issues and I think
that this book will really help me to
kind of think of this problem from a
different kind of point of view
to us it was a really it's a very
different kind of project first of all I
mean it's very personal it's something
that we started working on because we
have
a family member at home my dad who had
dementia
it was very gratifying in the same
moment it was a little bit saddening
because it seems to affect everyone's
lives but then at the same time we did
get the sense that we had put something
out there that a lot of people might be
able to use in in a positive way and
might be able to integrate and might be
able to bring them some sort of
um creative spark or or some kind of
relief in the struggles that they're
facing with with caring for somebody
with this with this illness
[Music]